some of hong kong's most prominent
democracy campaigners have been
sentenced for their roles in the 2019
anti-government protests
media tycoon jimmy lai has just been
handed a second
jail term of eight months he'd already
received a 12-month sentence for
unauthorized assembly during the
demonstrations meanwhile martin lee who
is 82 and known as hong kong's father of
democracy
has been given an 11-month suspended
sentence
almost 1.7 million people took part in
pro-democracy marches
in the city back in 2019.
and we have correspondent phoebe kong
who is standing by with the view from
hong kong
live for us now phoebe tell us these
sentences just been handed down
what more do we know
[Applause]
i'm now standing at the court building
where the judge
just handed down all the sentences for
10 leading
figures of the opposition came and the
last group of crowd is now
like chanting protest slogans express
their support to their jailed defendants
as you have mentioned in the report that
the jimmy jimmy light media tycoon
will have to go to jail for more than a
year
that he was sentenced for two cases
about his role in the unauthorized
assembly back in august 2019 that in
total
he has to serve uh 18 months in jail
just for two just for these two cases
and uh
apart from that among the ten defendants
five of them
were given uh suspended sentences that
means that although the judge
thinks that imprisonment is the only
option but offer
a suspended uh sentence for them uh
to uh like carry on so um
this is uh the in conclusion this is the
sentence we observe today
is a little bit old of expectation is a
little bit harsher than
observers analysis can expect that
because this is a charge
of uh not regarding the national
security but
rather unless serious charges among
other public order charges but
still the judge thinks that um she hopes
to send a deterrent
to the society and to other like
possible offenders of the similar
charges in the future
okay so it's being viewed as a signal
and just to let our viewers know you've
actually been looking at live pictures
there um
phoebe i mean we see the scenes outside
of the courthouse
what is the reaction been there's a lot
going on behind you
yes definitely like just now i'm like
walking out of the club room right after
the judge have finished her sentencing a
lot of supporters inside the courtroom
uh shouted and uh chanted slogans
uh to support the defendants or well
most of them have already been detained
like they want to show support uh before
they were taken away to prison
and maybe to disappear from the public
eye from a certain period of time
and the defendants themselves some of
them
they are responded by chanting slogans
like uh
peaceful rallies is not the crime that
we have spoke to some of the
activists who have come here to attend
the hearing today they
say this is uh literally a chilling
effect that were imposed to the society
because the charges
the conviction and the sentence we're
talking about today is about the
peaceful
protests that it will definitely send a
chilling effect to
other the the peaceful protesters who
want to
organize rallies uh without a permission
from the police
in hong kong thank you
and there are so many concerns about
what these sentences mean for democracy
in hong kong phoebe kang who we just
spoke with there
who uh she had the opportunity to speak
with one defendant the former chairman
of the hong kong democratic party about
how he
sees the increasing crackdown on dissent
a silver medal awarded to young son by
the government for his political work
it was something this former lawmaker
felt proud of
but 12 years later it seems to represent
a hong kong
that's been lost at that time the
central government in beijing
has still uh
adopt a tolerant approach to hong kong
china is my country and hong kong is my
home
but to love your country doesn't mean
you love a certain
political regime jung-sun was one of ten
defendants found guilty of
organizing or attending marches in 2019
during massive anti-government protests
many opposition icons of his generation
now
sentenced for the first time this just
the first of
six charges against jung-sum
the 73-year-old has taught at the
university of hong kong for decades
while also engaging in politics in court
he was the only defendant to read out
his submission
in person as a civil disobedience
i pled guilty but i don't feel remorse
because i don't think i have done
anything wrong
and so i don't miticate
my case and i won't go for
appeal imprisonment won't be a surprise
to me
jung-sum calls himself a moderate who
hoped for democracy under chinese rule
but that hasn't happened before hong
kong's handover from britain to china
jung-sum and fellow activist martin lee
set up the democratic party
they were among the first lawmakers
directly elected to voice dissent in the
chamber
and paved the way for hong kong's party
politics
but now the national security law and an
electoral overhaul
are making it difficult for opposition
parties
to even survive very difficult
very depressed they just reverse all the
pace of democracy
we have managed over the past 23 years
so this is a big
retreat of democracy in hong kong is it
worthwhile to stand for election again
or maintain the party politics i think
it's a big question
or whether we go back to the pressure
group politics
1970 the fight of his generation may
soon become history
but he doesn't think their efforts will
have been in vain
hong kong history is so full of
struggles i will never
disengage myself from politics and i
don't think i would leave hong kong at
all
democracy is not just about the party
politics not just about the voting
but also just how it affects our ways of
living
but i still insist on the rational and
peaceful
approach and i think this is the way to
solve the problem in the long run
yongsun believes democratic values are
now deeply rooted in hong kong's culture
his fight isn't over yet
and we can tell you that young son the
former chairman of the hong kong
democracy party featured in that report
has been given an
eight-month suspended sentence he is
facing five additional charges
let's speak now with steve sang he is a
political scientist
and the director of the soas china
institute
in london one of the world leading
centers of expertise on china
steve thank you so much for joining us
what does
what we have been witnessing today mean
for the hong kong
pro-democracy movement i think it's a
very sad day for hong kong's
democracy movement this is not
unexpected i think the um
on the stiff side sentences really have
been generally
expected and it is i think the judge was
trying to do a bit of a
balance between enforcing the law
technically
and allowing some of the sentenced
peoples to have suspended sentences but
still
it is going to send a very clear message
to many people in hong kong
that peaceful demonstrations are no
longer
tolerated and i mean we have had
developments we have to say
you know since these charges were
leveled since this trial
and i'm thinking about the other
pro-democracy cases which are now
pending in the courts
uh for example the nearly 50 activists
that have been charged with subversion
in february under the new national
security law
when you look at um at these most recent
charges what do you think we can expect
there and what does it say about the
direction
that hong kong is going in now the key
system is sentenced
today will not under the new national
security law and therefore could be
um calibrated much more in terms of how
the hong kong traditional judicial
systems operate
those new cases that are being charged
under the national security law
are likely to be sentenced much more
harshly
the whole arrangement under the national
security law is such that
only judges who are expected
to understand what the chinese
government wants to be done under the
national security law
will be allowed to seat and preside over
those cases
and therefore we can expect those cases
to be sentenced
in very harsh ways against the
defendants i think the results are
almost forgotten conclusion
wow you think it's you think it's that
definitive um that's really incredible
to hear
i i'd like to also ask you um you know
about these efforts to
have so-called only patriots in the
legislative council
um tell us a little bit more about what
you think about that and you know
what it means for one country two
systems
well it means the end of the one country
two systems
as the term was being understood in hong
kong historically
or by the rest of the world outside of
china
it doesn't mean the end of one country
two systems as the chinese government
understands it
because the chinese government's
understanding is that whatever the
chinese government says is one country
two systems
anyway now in terms of the
um future of any democratic
development in hong kong i think we have
to accept that
the national security law was introduced
to make sure that there is no more
democracy movement in hong kong that
democracy in hong kong
in the future will be democracy
with the characteristics of the chinese
communist party
which basically means that every
person who try to stand will have to be
vetted and being deemed as acceptable by
the communist party
or the chinese government and on that
basis then you can have a free
um an open election but if you are not
pre-approved by the communist party then
there is a bit of a problem
wow steve sang political scientist and
the director of psoas china institute in
london thank you so much for joining us
to share that expertise on
what is really a historic day for hong
kong we appreciate your insight
you're welcome
you